all right Jim Tomei is working for the
Major League Baseball Network coverage
from Fenway begins today at 3:00 and
will feature MLB tonight airing before
and after every game they do a great job
and it's good to have the hall-of-famer
back on the program Jim good morning how
are you oh it's great how's everything
it's been a long time yeah we're just
trying to figure this out with the
analytics that when you know that you
have Chris Sale on the mound the Dodgers
go all right handed so I got three guys
who hit at least 25 home runs and I got
the analytics saying I can't put them up
there against Chris Sale what do you
make of this well had been a big part of
where I think we've become where we're
heading forward in it it's about numbers
by the way I would send gibby up there
just so you know okay
I was upset Gibby I would have sent
gibby up with as they did as Tony you
know all his Tommy Lasorda did at the
time but you know the the analytics are
interesting because you know I also work
with the White Sox and and there's a lot
of information being put out there and I
think I I do believe that that some of
it is good and I do believe that you
have to go off of wisdom to time and
history and just being around the game
and as you said a minute I was listening
in the gut feeling and I think what made
all of those managers great is that they
had those gut feelings they had you know
they maybe said okay Kirk Gibson can hit
that backdoor slider even though he is
hurt you know Eckersley didn't throw
hard but maybe at that moment he could
have done that you know granted he was
hurt but he could still get to that
wraparound slider that Eckersley threw
and he did which you know that's why I
respect the guys that do have the gut
feeling but all those analytical guys
that bring the information down and they
put it in front of you I think there is
value to that as well but would you be
sitting out last night's game in your
prime if you're facing Clayton Kershaw
chris'll because it's lefty on lefty
yeah no I would not I would not I hope
well you may not have a choice in it
your manager might go looked at the
analytics Jim sorry you're not going to
face Chris Sale well that would have
been a bummer I'd be honest and Chris
Sale look look Chris Sale is a dominant
dominant left-hander and there were
there were those guys in our time Dan
that like you know the Randy Johnson's
you know when Randy was dominant those
were times that Espinoza would get that
start but overall but that's when you
wanted to sit down Jim when Randy
Johnson was on the mound you're okay if
your manager said hey there's always
that one chance that you could come up
with a big hit and you know that that's
where our games headed I really believe
it I think you know as you've seen with
bullpens I think we've seen it with you
know with with platoons and and you look
across the Dodgers you know whole staff
lineup they've they've got guys they got
guys that are sitting in that are
all-stars know and create you know to
their to their credit that's gotten them
there I just I like the old traditional
way I think you know that but Jim I'm
looking at this the last five complete
games in the World Series I think we've
only had five this this decade in the
last decade I think we've had no even I
in the last since the 2001 World Series
we've had five complete games in the
World Series no Johnny Cueto Madison
Bumgarner Cliff Lee Josh Beckett and
Randy Johnson yeah on the all dominant
I'll be honest and I you know like Lissy
this multi I think smokes he you know
cuz cuz smokey says a lot of great
things and you know that that era that
time during our nineties it it's just
changed so much and and I ask the
question is it because there are more
guys now that
roll harder and you can keep bringing
them out of the bullpen yeah but but you
know it's to me it's I hope that we
continue to see you know what the stat
like the five complete games
you know I gosh I mean the old
traditional starter that could go eight
you just don't see it no more and you
don't see it in postseason because of
the firepower that these bullpens have
that they can go to now the risk to that
is when you overuse them in and I know
this as a hitter if you keep running a
guy out there and I we get used to them
and we see their tendencies a guy could
still sew a hundred and get hit so
that's the fine line of bringing too
many guys in were like in a seven-game
series where guys you know are lining up
to get you know they get used to these
guys coming out of the pen Alex Cora
made all the right moves last night and
you know you make that switch you bring
in Nunez you know Baez was throwing some
cheese up there Jim and then you bring
in Alex wood and you know it's a
three-run homer that's where it's a gut
feeling and look Dave Roberts has done a
great job but in that moment it just
felt like man this guy's you know he's
bringing it and no I got a play I got to
play the the analytics here and not that
they lost because of that but it just
sort of you know that the spotlight
shined on that because you said all your
left-handers you want those matchups and
it didn't work out last night no it
didn't it didn't and that's the fun part
it might tonight you know enough look I
mean I think I'm the on the game last
night I said managers her getting more
scrutinized than ever and then it's
because of all the moves that are being
made
I mean Cora has done a fabulous job
I mean honesty he's kept the game
traditional you know he's hitting and
running he's you know he didn't steal a
guy at first base left the whole open
you know there's just little things that
I really think he's done a fine job and
you know as you will
then it's all about matchups and you
know but but are we overthinking the
game a little bit you know that's that's
the question I think everybody asked in
the postseason now and especially the
last two or three usually I think it
started I think it started when Andrew
Miller with Cleveland you know a few
years back you know when Tito was going
to Andrew and like the fifth and the
sixth that's that's when I really
started seeing like the total change of
the bullpens completely taking over the
postseason he's Jim told me the Hall of
Famer working for the major league
baseball Network as an analyst I got you
one four nine six strikeouts one home
run against Randy Johnson well I got the
one home but you know what I didn't fare
well he was yeah I mean you're you're a
at least I got the one but I got the one
later on you know in his career and I
was in Philly so I'll take it no doubt
about ok what is it like when you go
when you dig into the batter's box and
Randy Johnson's on the mound and he's
never in a good mood so what are you
thinking when you go to the play I'm
thinking as I know as I got established
for me I was thinking ok like hang in
there ok because he's he's tall six
eight six whatever he's his height is
his arm span like basically throws to
the plate it's coming out at yet and for
me it's you know getting mentally
focused try to try to hit a pitch and
don't miss it and if you miss it
it's not gonna be a fun at-bat look look
Randy Randy was if not the got most
dominant left-hander of all time you
know he was definitely in our time in
the 90s through the early when I don't
know when Randy retired but he is he was
incredible I he was a tough matchup you
know but but my mentality was always I'm
still gonna compete against ya and I'm
still gonna walk to that to home plate
and think I can get here no matter as
you read the numbers which
dominated me but I'll still think it no
doubt what's it like at the plate its
Fenway when you see that green monster
it's gosh I can I can see it right now
after all them years you look up the
green just II see it you it's just
tradition I don't know you know for me
it would just though to it locked yeah I
always felt like it when you come out of
the runway up in the dugout and the
first thing you see is the Green Monster
it just feels like it's a whiffle ball
field like man I I can I can hit one off
the wall there it looks so close did you
adjust accordingly to Fenway to try to
use the wall you know what I was just
gonna say it gotten typically Fenway got
me locked back in to going the other way
because you could get beat a little bit
and and and hit a ball the other way and
then hit the wall or go over it but it
always it always helped me get locked
back in wherever I left from there but I
see in the Green Monster like it just
was tradition man that's baseball that's
that's as good as it yep uh who wins
tonight what's it come down to tonight
with this pitching matchup who I liked
Christ I really do I think him pitching
the way he did last game I think you
know he made a few adjustments I think
they pointed that out on the network you
know where he's standing on the rubber
and but but but mainly I think he's
healthy I like Boston again to be honest
I they got a really good club man they
do a lot of things right and they got a
lot of firepower and I really liked how
hora has has gotten all them guys any
flow of the game the one pitcher comes
to mind if I say man I owned that guy
who comes to mind
oh my god I said I don't okay I don't
use the word own but I felt good on
Justin Verlander really yes believe it
or not I felt great on Verlander not
many people in there
I felt I felt great on Clemens I would
say the one guy Andy again I don't try
to use the word on that Rick Reed back
in the day was a guy that I had a ton of
success no I can understand that I could
understand that but you said Verlander
and Clemens yeah yeah I felt I felt good
on them I really did you have seven home
runs on Verlander yes
I don't know how many you hit off
Clemens how many do Polly do we have
Jim's numbers off clay maybe seven or
eight seven or eight off Clemens I think
yeah I'm not mistaken yeah I got in even
though yeah well you hit 600 home runs I
mean you had to take somebody deep a few
times here let me see Paulie do we have
Clemens we're checking we got eight
people working on this right now okay it
looks like he's got eight eight against
Clemens Clemens was listening now he'd
probably want to buzz the tower on you
for calling him out like this okay
that's that's you a big country boy you
just get right back up there and you
take your cuts you rub some dirt on a
gym and you're okay that's right in the
head did anybody throw at you like did
you ever feel like you know what that's
a purpose now no I really I mean look
look I was on the place I was all I was
all over the place I wanted to create my
strike zone I knew I wanted to leave
everything out of the equation of an
umpire calling the ball way
a Charlie Manuel and I when when when I
turned when everything started turning
for me for the right direction I think
getting on the plate was the best thing
I ever did and I felt like I controlled
the strike zone
now I struck out a bunch but I still
felt that if they made a mistake I was
gonna have the plate coverage to cover
the area yeah Mike I got Sabathia
smoking you once did I remember yeah but
but okay who's the guy you're not going
out and that you would give pause to go
out to the mound
no one does you mean look look if it's
called for and you get smoked or you
know like the way the game plays out and
you get hit so you go to them I mean
that's just baseball that's that's how
you're supposed that's how you earn
respect you know for you from your
teammates if you get hit I mean I don't
think you're every time looking to
charge the mob you can get a feel during
the game the other guys purposely like
throwing behind you and then you know
like like it's got it in you know
ultimately you know that's why retaliate
you don't you don't see I feel you don't
see you're not paying a lot of
retaliation but I do I do believe guys
will throw it guys
you know today they will do that for
sure I hope you're having fun with MLB
Network good to have you on gym and
congrats for all the success appreciated
good talking again and you as well
Thank You bud that's a Jim Thome Hall of
Famer working for MLB for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]